um so overall still a long way to  to go but yeah whatever i'll  try and try a bit better tomorrow but  this yeah this is upsetting  yeah i can understand you are in seventh  place  now in the preliminary so um are you  how are you feeling before that last day  what will be the tactics to secure  a place in the knockout i don't know  all right magnus thank you for joining  us we wish you the best of luck  tomorrow all right he left us definitely  magnus carlsen wasn't feeling too happy  right now  no i mean he kind of said it that it was  unnecessary  and uh it just happens you know he was  unsettled  by lavon aronian's brave attempt at  just making the position very very sharp  and sometimes that works but you know  one of the worst feelings in chess is  when you feel like you lost yourself  you did not sleep very well after that